these two teams played on monday night
last december in seattle yeah it was
three to nothing after three quarters
right this was anything but that kind of
boring this was exciting the kind of
football game i love both teams in the
30s exciting scoring big plays big
moments so many big moments that by the
end of the game you forget some of them
like how about the russell wilson tip
drill that resulted in a pick six only
his third interception of the year yes
and the second interception that went
for a touchdown for the other team i
mean and that's forgotten after all the
craziness that ultimately unfolded
that's how good of a game it was no
you're right it was full of big plays uh
had everything you want the drama all
that yeah russell wilson you never see
him make a mistake like that you know
thinks he's gonna bat it down bats it up
in the air volleyball style uh
you know to to your point mike you know
the funny thing is with the vikings and
the seahawks uh
you know they they've been defensive
teams for the last decade and they
clearly are not right now they play
through their offense on both sides of
the ball i mean seattle's got a top five
offense the vikings got a top five
offense and there was a lot of big plays
in the game in general i think that's
what made it a lot of fun you got some
superstar
like individual power on the defensive
side of the ball but neither defense is
something to brag about i guess is what
i would say there's concerns on on on
both of those defenses
and for you guys mike i mean you know
the the one thing and stop it i'm saying
you guys you got vikings okay the one
thing that uses silver lining too is hey
you know there you go you went into
seattle you had chances to win the game
you blew a coverage at one point um
and you know throw an interception which
was a highly contested ball back in your
own area there
and you did it without one of your best
players you know adam thielen not there
is a game changer and i think if this
matchup happens again in the playoffs
that minnesota can at least go up there
and go we can pull this off we're not
like totally out manned to where this
game's over automatically because we're
on the road in seattle
yeah and and here's the thing and this
is what was riding on the game because
after the loss yeah the vikings had the
furious comeback the final score 37 30
the vikings got 34 30 more coming up on
on my belief on where it went wrong and
why it went wrong but mike zimmer said
after the game it's not the end of the
world we're still waiting for well it's
not the end of the world but what it is
is this it's the beginning of what will
be a very difficult stretch for the
vikings now they need to win
at
a home against detroit and then they've
got the game at the chargers they have
the packers on a monday night coming up
in two weeks and six days and then they
finish with the bears they're gonna have
to get to the playoffs and they may get
there 12 and four as the six seed but
then the hard part begins because you're
going to have to go on the road three
times to get through super bowl if they
had won last night yeah it would have
been the start of something great
potentially because division title right
there bye week potentially right there a
lot easier path so they're going to have
to do it the hard way and they may have
more weapons available to them when the
time comes but they're gonna have those
weapons anyway in january it's always
better to get the home games that's what
was riding on last night and that's what
made it so important for the seahawks
who now have bumped the 49ers out of the
one seed right the seahawks are now the
two seed saints of the one seed by
virtue of the tiebreaker from earlier
this year but what think about that
both one seeds this weekend out new one
seeds in and that's how that's how much
was riding on that game yeah for both
teams and it really did have that
playoff feel to it and you do kind of
get the feeling that you'd like to see a
rematch of that game at some point in
january i would take it i mean hey let's
also not forget that dalvin cook came
out of the game in the third quarter in
the most crucial part of the football
game why the seattle seahawks were on a
24 to nothing run there you know
i got to think that that changes a
little bit if he's out there and it's
not quite the same outcome you know i'm
not saying they win the football game
but that was a huge ball to your team
halfway through the third quarter he
stumbles the ball all right they're your
team deal with it it's it's the one with
it so i'm referring to them as your team
for the rest of the year but uh yes it
is going to be a tough road on the
playoffs for anybody in the nfc because
yeah i don't care who you are if you get
a home wild card game or not you know to
have to go on the road to possibly
either seattle new orleans uh or seattle
san francisco or you know san francisco
seattle whatever you may it may be
however combination you want to talk
about that is going to be extremely
tough we do know that but i like your
minnesota viking football team mike and
of course i like the seattle seahawks
they're dangerous they're running the
ball well their defense has been very
opportunistic as of late their big thing
for me is gideon clowney's health as
long as he can stay healthy uh that's
when they are in the upper echelons of
the nfl when he's not you know i i worry
about their defense and whether they can
stop some of the really quality teams in
the nfc
quick observation too on the moment that
dalvin cook was injured because he
fumbled the ball it was 17 all at the
time right it opened the door for the
seahawks to take their first lead of the
game 20 to 17. but after that fumble
recovery right like i understand and i'm
not gonna do the get off my lawn thing
even though sometimes i would like you
to get off my lawn when we do the class
picture stanley cup photo in the end
zone after every turnover can we at
least keep our eyes open cameramen and
women and people in the truck for the
possibility that there's a serious
injury 30 yards back up the field that's
far more important than seeing a bunch
of seahawks defensive players mug for
the camera after a fairly routine fumble
recovery because cook was down and as
they went to break it looked like he was
sobbing on the field it looked like he
was crying on the field you're right
yeah that's what i thought too yeah yeah
and and i mean a significant injury for
the vikings they said it was shorter
after the game they said it's chest and
they're saying he's gonna be able to
play on sunday but i think back to the
adam feel and hamstring injury and it's
like i'll believe it when i see it yeah
because they kind of rushed him back and
the the other side of it too alexander
madison is not a huge drop from dalvin
cook no if they don't have cook then i
think they'll be okay but there's this
i'm gonna i'm gonna defer the next
segment the the the one key moment that
i think uh merits the most criticism for
kirk cousins because kirk cousins was
great yeah right yeah they were down 17
points and he he the the blown coverage
of quan treadwell
good for him actually catching the ball
they score the long touchdown and next
thing you know it's a 10-point game
right then the vikings get the ball back
remember there was that fake punt that
felt like the dagger oh that felt like
the game was over
yeah right
dk metcalf fumbles yep and then the v
and kirk cousins had and i gotta give
him credit because how many times do we
criticize chris a quarterback who is in
the final 10 minutes of the game
down two scores lackadaisical
nonchalant taking his good old time no
sense of urgency cousins was on it and
he knew what he had to do and he was
getting those guys at the line of
scrimmage and he was lining them up and
he was calling the plays and he was
being decisive and they got the ball
down the field and what a little
beautiful little lob and what a catch by
kyle rudolph to make it 34 30. i mean
cousins was on fire last night the
numbers don't reflect it but he was he
spread the ball around to nine different
guys he made good decisions he made good
throws it was it was fun to watch and it
really felt like he was going to finally
shed that that negative that oh and now
he's on eight on monday night football
he's going to chance and get to get a
chance in a couple of weeks to get his
first monday night football win but it
wasn't his fault last night no it really
wasn't and it was almost his credit and
his performance that willed the vikings
back into i agreed i think he is a man
on the mission i i think he's totally
aware of course and you've always said
this of all the the talk around him i
mean you know the announcers uh you know
joe tessitore and booger mcfarland they
acknowledge that you know he he he
thinks monday night football is special
and wants to get a win on it so he knows
what's going on out there i i will say
this
yeah i really do think this is a
different vikings team than we've seen
the last two years you know whether they
can make a run in the nfc playoffs i
don't know but the thing i do like about
their team in general they're tough they
run the ball they make big plays in the
pass game and run game a lot right other
than turnovers explosive 20-plus yard
plays are the number two stat that
dictates wins and losses you got that
your defense is a little scary but my
big point is this
i do see
a
you know i don't know what i want to say
a common thread as far as just unity
within a team that i like to see uh with
teams that are successful i really do
you you see it on your sidelines right
now too just the way stefan diggs and
and cousins and the defense and
everybody interacts you could tell uh
it's a team that's very close that way
and to me they are still a dangerous
football team yeah they're probably
gonna have to go on the road and do it
the hard way but i think they are the
type of team come play off time that is
going to be a pain in the butt and is
made to play on the road because of the
run game and the style of offense they
play and of course you got some studs on
defense to go along with it
the way it's shaping up right now
they're gonna have to go to lambeau
field yep to start the postseason yeah
then they're gonna have to go to new
orleans or san francisco or seattle in
the divisional round and then if you win
that congratulations you're gonna have
to go to new orleans or san francisco
seattle right or maybe even dallas who
knows right by the time it's all said
and done and let me say this before we
take a break because when we come back i
want to talk about the moment where i
think kirk cousins did make his biggest
mistake in the night but the xavier
rhodes blown coverage yeah and
and and they immediately told us that he
was expecting safety help over the top
what the hell was he expecting harrison
smith was in front of him yeah what did
he think was behind him i don't know
right exactly right i i'm not fine
when are people when are people gonna
say xavier rhodes doesn't belong on the
football field he's a liability chris
and the only reason he's on the team is
because of how much guaranteed money he
had this year if his contract did not
tie the vikings hands he would not be on
the team no and they have him out on the
field in key moments what the hell is
mike zimmer thinking yeah no i i
understand that if there's a weakness to
your team it is the depth of your
defensive run seven okay the depth of
your defensive front seven which you saw
kind of get worn down a little bit as
the game went on and then yeah i don't
trust your corners and especially xavier
rhodes you're right i mean the problem
is you guys want to play nickel defense
all the time so you need three corners
in there and you know i think he's still
a part of the best three you got on the
football team even though i think
michael hughes and base defense he
should be the guy that starts outside
and says instead of xavier rhodes
michael hughes mackenzie alexander
holton hill what happened to halton hill
yeah you're right where did he go no
you're right i'm wrong it's more than
three they need to you're right they
might have to think about benching
xavier rhodes i don't think that's a
crazy thought at all mike i think
everything you said is spot on i forgot
about mackenzie alexander after the
david moore touchdown yeah he had been
targeted four times he had given up four
catches 99 yards right and a touchdown
and he had a stupid late hit out of
bounds that gave the seahawks 15 yards
in the first half so i i don't know what
it is um but but at some point i think
uh you know if and i'm sure they've
talked to him and they've talked to him
they've talked to him and they see those
flashes of good
and they focus on those and they think
they can iron out the bad well at some
point you have to accept the fact you're
not ironing out he's too big they're
just he's too big that's the thing
kicking the can to the end of the season
and he's going to be gone after the
season all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports